our next guest a man who is called 15
consecutive nba finals and has been a
voice of the knicks since 2004
and he has been waiting to accept what
uh he was awarded and
uh if you will inducted with last
year it was the 2020 curt gowdy award
winner he will go into the
basketball hall of fame on friday
it's been a long time coming and very
well deserved one of our favorites here
on the rich eisen show mike breen
on the rich eisen show how are you mike
hello old friend
nice to hear your voice nice nice live
talking to each other and
of course this is always the time of
year where it's like right around the
time rock
i'm watching your sprinting ability on
various
videos on twitter all the time
how long before you you sprint how long
do you stretch
oh mike you're getting into a very
touchy very touchy subject
uh about my prep for it this year my
prep
for it was to go on an anti-inflammatory
um cleanse i dropped 12 pounds
um about in three weeks prior to the run
didn't run faster it's my start and my
finish
um and that has now been um confirmed by
uh analytics that is actually true so
it's all of that
that's my way now as we get older is
just
if you come away without an injury it's
it's a wild success
in one piece mike i came away with one
piece but the best number is what we
raised for st
jude children's research hospital which
is as you know what it is
all about in this world doing whatever
we can while we're here you know what
i'm saying well that's one of the
magical places on earth
it is beautiful um so thanks for joining
today mike i appreciate it
congratulations and
this is going to be this has to be a
hell of a speech you've been working on
it for a year i imagine
coming on friday right no pressure no
pressure uh you know what it's funny i
did i didn't because
you know it was postponed a couple of
times it was supposed to be in august
i'm like i have all summer and then
it clearly wasn't gonna happen in summer
they said maybe october i said all right
i'll wait i'll wait till the fall and
then i got pushed back till may so i
just started working out about about 20
minutes ago
sort of like me with my run
[Laughter]
no it's it's um it's it's very exciting
it's very very humbling
um and it's actually been beautiful
because you get to uh
you get to hear from so many friends and
family and colleagues
many that you see all the time many that
you haven't heard from all
in a long long time and uh to be able to
um to share it with them and to be able
to thank them for
for all the the things that they did for
you uh is uh
it's really it is as you said earlier
it's what it's all about it is what it's
all about so
uh we can confirm here live on the rich
eisen show that you will not be using
your speech
like jordan to settle all the old scores
with people who wouldn't give you jobs
in your shot
early on i didn't say that i didn't say
that
that one time you know when i was in
fordham and i tried you know like
you could i mean just really you can
just lay you that but that's not like
you i don't think that's what you're
gonna do mike i don't think that's what
you'll be no
of course not but what would you if you
had told that kid in fordham back in the
day that this is what
this is what uh had become what what
would you say
mike bring that kid growing up no i mean
i
wouldn't have wouldn't have believed any
of it i mean i've told this story many
times
um i went to fordham with with my
wonderful friend michael k
we've been best friends for over 40
years and we used to sit in the student
cafeteria
and you know we're both student
broadcasters at the college radio
station and we talk about what we want
to do
and i i would say boy my dream job would
be broadcasting the knicks and he would
say my
dream job broadcasting the yankees and
then would have a good laugh like
these two fools thinking along those
lines so it's you know it's nothing you
ever
you ever dream about uh but then as it
you go through it you just
you know you feel so uh so blessed and
some
in many aspects you don't feel like you
deserve all the wonderful blessings you
had and
and michael and i talked about that in
fact you know not to go on
off tangent but um i got a text from him
yesterday
that was something that i'll always save
it was just
such beautiful words that he sent and
and that to me has been
the most wonderful part of this always
is him being able to tell me something i
meant me being able to tell him
something back and and and you know
how much i love him as a friend so those
kind of things when you think back
all those years ago and then come to now
it just it gets a little overwhelming
emotionally
okay is one of my favorite people i mean
he's a he's he's
a great human on the planet who is just
one big
um one big um great human
that's he is just the he i love that guy
and you know i'm not just because he
invited me to his christmas party with
danny aiello in the basement
you know of his apartment years ago
standing shoulder to shoulder with just
so many people who are just
i i imagine you were at those parties
too mike you must have been at this
i was and then i you know i realized
there was a possibility that
some of those parties could go sideways
and it might not be the best place to be
no they were they were great events and
it was you know what it was rich
it was bringing all people together in
our business right
and it was just so much fun because
often it was it was people that you
didn't hadn't seen for a whole year
since the last party
no doubt well congrats in advance of
your of your induction it is so well
deserved and i couldn't be more
happy for you and then look at what
we've got going on tonight here in los
angeles
mike breen um i don't know what's more
surprising
um the fact that the lakers are having
such a struggle
in you know an injury-riddled struggle
or the fact that the knicks have the
same record as the lakers coming into
this game they
they have the same record and the team
that is on the upswing
because they are they are more i guess
well put together and
and healthier are the knicks what is
this renaissance been like to
to call and see front and center mike
well i i think all of us when when we
think about our favorite teams
that we root for regardless of what
sport it is
to me that the most enjoyable seasons as
a fan
whether it be for me like a met fan or
a football giant fan or a nick fan were
the
with the the years where the team just
completely over achieves and they come
out of nowhere and surprise you
with their terrific play and their
success those are always the fun ones
the years were
you know one of your teams as a
championship contender and you think
they should win the title or could
i mean they're great obviously and
especially if they do win it but i've
always felt
these are the kind of years that are
most satisfying and the and the teams
that fans remember and that's what i
feel about this team
because you know for nick fans it's been
years
of really torture in terms of
you know so desperate so hungry just to
have a contending team
and it seems every year right after the
all-star break the season goes off the
cliff for whatever reason
and for them to be a team that every
month seems to get better
um that's what's been really fun and and
you know early
defense carried them now all of a sudden
they've had one of the best offensive
teams over the last month
they're one of the best three-point
shooting teams in the league i mean that
was their number one weakness coming
into the year
it's it's incredible and and i think i
said on the air during a game on msg
last week before a game i said the
knicks have the eighth best record in
the nba
and then i said let me repeat that i
almost couldn't
believe me saying it that he had the
eighth best record in the entire league
and it's a credit to you know starting
with pivotal
and then with players who just who are
willing to be coached hard and bought in
and are willing to sacrifice individual
um successes for team success it has
been so much fun to watch rich because
they play the game that many of us love
when it's
you know what's the old expression um
the whole is better than the sum of its
parts
and they are the epitome of that that
said they've got a hell of a part in
julius randle i've got mike breen here
on the rich eisen show where did he come
from
we all know obviously how his his his
uh his career and that's a big game in a
big spot tonight obviously here
in the home of the lakers uh and just
watching him it's just been for me
and you know i go way back too and where
i'm from seeing him in bernard king's 30
is just
jarring um and and how good he is
and what he is doing and carrying on
that terrific tradition of that
number and his mvp type worthy mvp type
play
where did how did this all come together
for julius randle best you can tell
mike well i i think he went last year
was
was one of the hardest years of his
career if not the hardest because he was
coming to new york to
you know assume leadership and and now
show that he could be
the guy and it didn't work out and and
amazingly he's been so public about that
that the piece he wrote in the players
tribune
uh i would say to anybody who hasn't
read it read it and you'll become an
instant fan of
julius randle because he took a hard
look in the mirror and realized
yeah i can do some things i have some
talent but boy was i not a good leader
or a team basketball player last year
and and his numbers were okay he was
like 19 and 10 for crying out loud most
guys the gay i did my job
but he didn't think that in fact he
think thought he
he did a poor job and what he he spent
his whole time off
improving on every aspect and that's the
thing
that that blows me away he's improving
on every facet
of his game not just shooting but
shooting from the free-throw line
his mid-range shot his three-point shot
um
he's improved his defense not just his
on-board defense but his help defense
he's improved his decision-making he's
improved his leadership
it's it's one of the biggest one-season
turnarounds
of a player that i've seen in in almost
thirty years a broadcast in the n b
a and it's because he realized that he
fell short
looked in the mirror and said i'm going
to do something about this it it's uh
it's truly a a terrific incredible story
of
of of a one-year turnaround for a player
like that so obviously
you know uh the playoffs are gonna start
very soon there's that one game
uh play-in if they're if the seven seed
is lucky enough
um and then obviously a tournament uh
could actually
unfold from all of that so um and
we know that lebron is not very keen on
that uh
idea and that starts very soon the best
team that you've seen
this year mike breen would be would be
which obviously you've seen a ton come
through madison square garden and then
your work with the nba
uh on espn and abc what do you got for
me
on that front here well to me the the
the most dangerous team the team that
look
look to me to be the most unbeatable and
it was only for a short stretch
and obviously their whole success
possibilities
is about their health is brooklyn bro
brooklyn
if those three guys are healthy and
playing together
they're they're unguardable as much as
any team that i i've seen and
you know golden state is is certainly in
in a category like that when when they
had the three of them
but they're phenomenal but right now
health is
is the number one intangible it always
is every season but
nothing like this year and i think it's
brought everybody kind of
closer in terms of whose championship
contenders
i don't i don't think i ever remember
saying
that i could actually see eight
different teams
win the title this year i don't think
i've ever said that um
if you said five that would be a lot but
i really do believe
eight teams have a legitimate shot and
and you know all the intentional
intentionally we just talked about have
something to do with it
but phoenix and utah have been
tremendous all season
they're they're right there the clippers
and yes the lakers as well
and i put denver in there as well even
without your mom murray
denver's got a chance and then you put
the top three teams of philly brooklyn
and milwaukee
all have a chance and um it depends on
who's healthy it depends on who's
obviously clicking at the right time uh
but it's as wide open as i've ever seen
in all my years doing the league well
then
to use your uh your uh
well-known phrase of bang um
steph curry has been maybe the bangiest
of them all
certainly in recent days um
who's your mvp mike what do you think
who would you put a vote for on that
front
i i would and i do think you really need
this year to wait to the very end of the
season
uh because there's still so many
important games and we kind of tend to
to have our votes all set like a month
ago
but to me with so much at stake still
these games are huge
and to see how somebody performs in
these gauge these games for example
jamal murray goes down and
jokic says okay i got you don't worry um
that showed me a lot so right now i
would say he's he's the guy that that i
would go for
just for his consistency um for his
overall
what he does for that team night in a
night out and quite frankly his ability
to stay on the court
um is you know that's one of the the key
statistics for every team this year
so i would lean towards him right now i
mean it's important that you say
consistency to stay on the court because
you mentioned the nets are the most
potentially unbeatable unguardable and
you can't talk about any of the three as
an mvp of the league
you can however to use a similar analogy
that you just made about anybody could
win the championship of eight teams
you could make a case for eight mvps
eight different mvps i think you could
probably get close to that
you know donovan mitchell before he went
down would be somebody you'd have to
mention chris paul for the sons you've
got to talk
obviously about embiid in philadelphia
steph curry
uh for for the warriors and i know
they're barely above 500 and then i
guess to come a little bit full circle
julius randle what he's done with the
knicks
fatigue because he's one to interrupt
the voter against
he's been phenomenal so you know the
talent in the league is
is right now it's it's crazy uh in terms
of how many guys are playing
at such a such a high level um and
that's why like i
you know you mentioned randall uh i'm
happy for him
uh he's finally gonna get to to plan a
playoff game
never played the playoff game in fact
the best team he's ever played on
record wise was 12 games under 500
and this is again it's a this is a
really talented player coming out of
colleges
so now he's going to get a chance and
and you know to to be able to see a guy
get that opportunity is
uh it's always to me one of the one of
the fun parts and and that's
that's also why it's worked in new york
with sibido because
so often for coach do you get the player
at the right time
at the right time of his career where
he's ready to to do whatever it takes to
win
i've always loved isaiah thomas's
comment from years ago he said young
players define their games by how many
points they score
but then you go the older veterans
define their games by how many playoff
wins they get
and with julius randle right now yeah
he's like he's enjoying the scoring but
but he wants playoff wins well we'll see
what happens tonight with the lakers um
before i let you go mike excuse me for
being ignorant about this but is this an
in-person
ceremony on friday you get it to
actually be together
or is that possible or is this all yes
okay yes and that's that's the best part
about it so
all my family's coming my mother's gonna
be there my brothers are gonna be there
uh plenty of friends and colleagues so
it'll be uh
it'll be a fun night for all of us it's
a long wait but one
um that you're finally gonna get to
enjoy i couldn't be happier for you mike
you know how i feel about you so i'll
just say publicly i don't care
well um my dear friend real excited i
always appreciate you right back at you
mike breen enjoy the
enjoy friday and then we'll catch up
with you during the playoffs gotcha
that's mike breen everybody
yes you got the uh uh the knicks and the
lakers tonight
and then he's gonna call his 16th
straight nba finals
coming up this summer hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here